[Music]
[Music]
I'm looking right now
[Applause]
get my phone and mute this
[Music]
much time to death good supporter make
this easier I think didn't walk away
sure
let me get up man you gotta get this 25
to life if you do that it's really bad I
don't know I'm not I can't survive in
here I don't belong in here man hey I'm
sure you'll be fine you don't get it man
we're [ __ ] in here just try to calm
down okay
worrying about it will make it easier I
know I just can't help it you're up get
in there
there you go saying this
[Applause]
that's all I need look look funny copper
get undressed I don't want to get
injured right I take off my boat big
nasty
let me clapping
name a nympho - nothing what you gonna
do tell them no I think you enjoy a
little too much
[Laughter]
I go go plane spray away baby are you
done yet a little suspect over there go
along I can your phones
hello prevail it will fight in here
every damn day uh it's way too crazy in
this joint
you're not on a vacation this is a
[ __ ] prison what's up Xbox battery I
don't think I've ever seen like the
lagging I'm just trying to toughen you
up yeah I'm not the tough tight no [ __ ]
man they've been spraying you for a
minute you sure you got skin after this
you gotta massage
it just seems a little excessive yeah
let me retweet the let you kill make us
play you for the rest of it let me go
get me a burger go go get me a burger
I'll be back the captain caboose says
you ain't going to be able to sit for a
week after that hearing my buddy grandma
back all right can you guys my name is
Williams and this is my prison you too
Freddie West Janelle oh yeah
this dude's the beard once we lock users
in here
oh yeah I'm right there I haven't
checked the mail today right there yeah
I'll be I'll be down there later I don't
know
keep going we'll keep walking watching
my boobies and so therefore the meaning
that dudes walking up to the tear or
negative first let's go inside hey relax
I said do it do it
take it easy man what's wrong with you
close up cell 48
I keep going I'm gonna sit down
Kiki will be keys let's go can you sit
down get dressed
look how blurry this picture is when
that's this that's the Esk going right
there
now mother please you picked you clean
you fix it already with the with the
slander we ain't even had a praise in
here kid we ain't even at a prison
you're a king
look at that look someone wants to talk
to him yeah oh I don't know man
so over there that's all I know listen
to you my god oh look it kid King King
don't even want to come up approached me
himself you gotta sit he got his little
man after me man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
no I can't
are you doing that man is too much for
me I'm gonna do some push
follow chinos I don't want to push the X
button all day bit cloudy sit down the
down the iron Dan the iron Lords
podcaster serving life are not both
what's the code ominous maxilla
[Music]
look man we do a life but we scheming
man we scheme it wait we'll be doing
life forever what the hell are these
guys
[Music]
hey let me go there you are man King oh
let me get my ass beat Larry it's about
what Harvey wants now got this I got
this
oh maybe cuz you win because he did not
stay the hell away from me okay that's
right king stay away from me we ain't
friends
this ain't the Salvation Army I ain't
trying to be friends with everyone
looking for clothes
what's up big heath come on oh god all
day late now I want to buy things yeah
next mmm
my birthday is coming up that's why all
right [ __ ] I need get you go and then
spin those birthday books yeah I got
like 15,000 incredibly pleased uh hold
on very bad never run about okay
so everyone can hear everyone fun
there's no people can't hear us want to
make sure that the audio because I'm
talking about in my Yeti I'm not talking
out of the mic that's on this talking
out of my Yeti
is there a way to turn king up let me
see how low is he
I will try that I'm gonna see how that
works you drink a gallon of lemon water
you can run it to the bathroom all day -
all right sounds better seat taken
yeah get lost talk up a couple minutes
game what up now oh dude this guard is
pushing me because you can't go that way
man are you here trying trying to have
that conversation I want to eat hey is
someone talking no and you wonder the
chat man if you guys be so kind
definitely share this on Twitter and
stuff man let all the realm know that we
in here I know I've made like three
posts because of all the issues that
we've had
I'm bet so so so keen should I hear the
matter should I show force so forth sure
looks like it all right what are you
gonna do about anything know about this
oh yeah that's right move out the way si
let me get this let me get this grub man
I hit this big goddamn restaurant oh no
he ain't doing nothing all right he
ain't doing nothing Oh miss
oh oh they they but establish where they
gonna get us man they're gonna get deep
here hold this man even do nothing
they really don't like me Shantanu
Microsoft let just publish the game King
that's what we did that's out of control
son it's out of control
yeah I'll have poking cops while we in
there firmly course I'm in there firmly
making my big nose I don't know how I
feel about this but making fun of my
nose I'm so conscious about my nose man
then make fun of a whole life for this
dumb sausage pause I'll even need a
knife is that people tend can't want to
stab your jugglers my number is missing
man what's your beef with that guy
anyway uh let's just say it's a long
story but don't worry about him he's out
her picture now could you do me a favor
like what there's something I need
what's that exact constructor god man
it's simple I just need you to watch my
back while I get it that's all
sorry not interested would you just tell
me no wait yep what you can't just walk
out of here horse again we're gonna both
end up in the hole well I don't have a
choice
alright alright I'll help you just don't
get caught okay keep your eyes sharp
yeah let's see if you do your job right
okay I'll distract the nurse just watch
out for her
alright are you back in this was like
The Last of Us 2 graphics I need a way
from that you know what I'm getting out
of here tell me is that nurse yeah sorry
but I'm a bit bored here you know I
don't know it's not up to me but I'm
sure he won't be too long watching turn
around at the last minute okay thank you
oh you better get that sorry I'm just
getting restless here you gotta do
something about that guard King bout me
you see that that's what you do and
that's what you do
now let me take this
I got it
I'm waiting for oh god oh go go go keep
their keep amazing amazing you're coming
up oh no God places I mean it feels like
it's all over you know it's really bad
mm-hmm
let me know when you're kidding someone
so that nose is in 4k no it's not
because I got it yes that's not extreme
work take the more dominant strain now
let me ask you guys a question do you
guys mind seeing who's talking at the
top left should I just remove that
because I'm pretty sure you guys know
what we sound like by now none of no
people join in that's true shout to
Emperor what's bigger his nose to the P
that's fine the digital edition he got
the digital nose
so what's your plan
excuse me I know what you're up to I
don't know what you're talking about
zero come on four six five don't be
making fun of my name that's my number
huh I don't know why you ain't got my
number
I appreciate what you did back there but
you need to back off well hell hey Oh
God I'm sure you have good reasons to
bust out of here
but I need you yeah you're gonna have to
get one you'll have to get just offer oh
you're that man I try to make these
friends man you try to do that like you
did in the infirmary back there you
trying to be funny
no I'm not listen I'm pretty much in on
this just trying to make you understand
that you could really use my help
like I said I can handle myself
even though we've been talking to it
the walls are thin in here am I supposed
to believe that let's just say that you
and me have something in common we both
want him dead
oh you don't know [ __ ] about me man
maybe not but Harvey kills someone very
close to me
with over that that's right
I'm going after how are you gonna catch
these damn pretty damn sure our chances
with my work and you know that
Harvey's mine
I'll share no hobbies nah man you got to
share this hardly pause you know you
don't shut you down
it sucks you hear somebody turn this
dude's mic night your to be said big
pause facts
who keep knocking at my damn window yeah
duh it's like bland and I decide what
goes down you got that sure whatever you
say I mean it man
you [ __ ] this up I'll kill you myself
yeah I get it
mmm so what's your plan you know I'm
gonna start outbreak and everybody gonna
turn but phases we're gonna call them
clickers are you saying the origins on
how last of us started look at that
leave it to Sony to like King say their
origins before they say their own idea
I'll give you that Jonathan B says this
is the Last of Us pre for me out but if
it wasn't for me you'd still be in there
don't forget I saved your ass twice I
don't know about that saving my ass part
but I'll give you this it did help out a
little bit a little bit Benson a little
bit right
I really appreciate how much time stuff
goes into games nowadays I ain't gonna
front I'll be paying that uh he says the
outbreak came from his nose no for real
in the ocean and then they morphed into
clickers underwater clickers
there's really people following IOP just
to dislike everything they do we got a
dislike on roadies shout out to them man
I respect them I know they are but God
let's see less man miles and our way
miles and our Lord
Oh got a minute
be right back guys oh we got black
people I need to get up from that roof
can you make it out there it's gonna
cost you you know I'm good for it
just get me up there
they couldn't get no black actors it
sounds like the same guy he just changes
with our gosh deeper yes I want to be a
black person to the deeper voice need to
change us hey no sorry we're full I'm
sure we could figure something out right
I guess we could use a few extra hands
around here black got mad juice yo hurry
up but we don't have all day
we're eating right here hey she up there
yeah we need to get up there somehow
all right hope here we go he said I need
to get up there yeah you're doing all
the work man this is my plan we don't
play this game we're gonna do a little
work here man a little work swab that
I'm swabbing all day long
hey guard my broom just broke well don't
just stand there get a new one oh oh oh
I can't break mine now cuz you broke
yours
I got a do manual labor cuz you decided
to break yo [ __ ] first that's bull hey
man it looks like you missed a spot
yeah seems like I had thank you you're
welcome
I haven't seen you before first time
working up here
Oh all those my words yeah it's my first
every job in this joint and Macy's oh I
think we're gonna get monetize look man
best part a clean toss a huge thing we
toss a youth clean I just need to
distract that guard don't worry about me
I'll take care of the first they doing
[Music]
how do you keep from going crazy so
crazy think about my other job and
what's that what's that my magician why
don't you some feedback on your mind for
mine yeah yeah hold on let me take it
out put it back in it pause looks like
hard work up here
are you kidding dad are you kidding me
well you know you get to be outside and
look at the view
holy [ __ ] man if you like this view then
you've definitely been inside wait too
long you what are you doing
ha just looking around go back to work
hey my broom is broken just stay here
alright alright
distract them
destroy well I'm not supposed to
distract the guard come on get over get
over
I can't run the man is mad slow as his
nose it's is no [ __ ] oh I don't need to
hear that hit up there get up there you
what are you doing nothing just uh
looking around I got your new broom come
here
sure now get back to work
yeah I notice how the cops look
imaginary I got the chisel good stick in
your pocket just need to get back again
so I hear you're the guy who knows how
to get things around here well it
depends on what you want
a record player can you help with that
sorry huh gadelle place with the record
get a man hey can I ask you something
what's up look isn't being a prison
guard almost like being in prison I mean
you're in here all the time with us are
you being a smartass come on man I'm
just trying to strike up a conversation
here oh all right I'll leave you alone
you better on somewhere I don't know
where but I'm sorry joint doing it in
the back I mean of course it's locked
thanks I got you girl let me out wait
I'll break the lock for you let's go
let's go get out of it oh don't act like
nothing just watch your mouth swabbing
the deck baby
[Music]
let's get it criminal masterminds oh you
did this break room hey man I got you up
there to get the chisels right this is
the part where we're sovereign lost his
mind
sovereign lost his mind yeah so Fred got
some special for you to read yeah man
I'm sure chisel you can do some crazy
damage too so not mad man you trying
trying to get out telling you in there
color
don't mess up king you coming you coming
to come and come and cover you talking
excuse me what I'm distracting them I'm
going I'm gonna go soon
could I have some extra sheets no it's
not gonna happen he said no he said no
he said no he said no forget it
I'm going I'm going go get out of his
jail cell bra set these streets
oh please these are coming out got the
egg spot
right here right here right next to me
all right all right sorry yeah I'm
freezing
could I have some extra sheets no it's
not gonna happen you'll edit you're at
it I'm going I'm going oh God nah not
today post my turn Oh get it now come on
the tool now it's my turn to be the
lookout all right hold up this own Chi
hey what's up fam you could start not
this guy just let him go past I'm gonna
do a fresh start okay and we read this
chat a little bit
a lot of Shawshank in this game
addicts having flashbacks to when he was
locked up now you need to cancel the
chisel fun fact addict did a three-year
bid for drea for driving well needless
stop stop stop stop
you should just let him pass don't try
to distract them why do you got two
dudes now wow I can distract him I could
distract him just do it a little bit let
him go just let him go don't bother okay
don't go I just want to knock this out
better start back because that dude
coming down you could probably get a
little bit of it done alright so yeah
how did he not see yo that was crazy we
can use like what you do it oh okay we
we don't need commodes anyways what you
need your commode is your business mad
push-ups come on me I'm looking at the
Loews I think you should be remove that
ass over here Daria I can't distract him
I can distract them yeah you distract
them you got this you got this
my joy done son ye-yeah real-life
criminals all right the tsul'kalu call
our door that the slit slick hair back
in the big nose dude god forbid you got
a duty it's over son
[Laughter]
like why you're gonna stay let's go
I mean freedom boy more pull that thing
yeah pull the toilet bowl back I'm going
to to butt out my face boy oh go away
stop screaming oh man I gotta press a
they switch it up now no you can run
right what button okay you gonna press
it on the arm yes this is a fan
not aim it things that interest
we gotta zoom in okay homie yeah I'm
coming I'm coming
well break that pipe Oh peachy with the
pipe all right we got stop the fan man I
can't do the push-ups remember I'm
trying - let's do it man why isn't that
doing it because you need how you need
me to help you open and come and help me
hold up let me see if we can get in
see this way
see if you can find something else like
turn the fan off or something got it
all right shut down you can go through
now Leo I need your help here
let's go where that's hot yeah what is
that joint those guards is coming
regularly now they don't come no more
pull
check this out what are you thinking I'm
thinking sheets all right let me hear it
okay
we need to find a way into this rule
once we do that we can get the sheets in
here it sounds easy enough problem is
they don't allow inmates in there you
think we can sneak in somehow yeah but
we're gonna need to get a hold of a
laundry cart once we have the cart one
of us has to hide in it the guard will
inspected and then bring it to the
bathroom what do you mean they're gonna
inspect as long as we're covering us in
sheets we should be fine okay
who's getting these dirty sheets I feel
like that that's a king job that's a
king job I'm a dirty up them sheets so
now you get in dirty sheets you ain't
dirty anything uh-oh my mama dirty paws
like weak will you talk about how you go
dirty some sheets
it's a nasty season there hey hey man
because what oh yeah what do you want
all right I won't bother you then well
that ship has sailed hasn't
what do you want yeah so I uh I just got
assigned here could you tell me how
things work well it's not so complicated
laundry comes in laundry goes out you
know that's it okay I need a laundry
cart
Oh can I have your number please what do
you need that for
it's rules and regulations nothing I can
do about it this week just a card man oh
I don't think so man I need a laundry
cart oh we need a laundry cart man
Jonathan B says Lord of laundry laundry
well let's get that cart I love how we
just completely stronger who's getting
in the dirty lon
[Laughter]
[Music]
open up the lid put the cheese in there
yeah more sheets we need more cowbell
[Music]
you be an extra you be an extra there's
no reason to be this expert yourself
hi oh you know I don't want to touch
this I know
I'm swinging you're both going we both
going the hole man we both go go VI we
both go to ver okay see what we have
here
you got nothing man nothing get out of
the way what if I exited right now what
would happen I kind of want to exit just
to see how this happens don't wait don't
exit yet I'll tell you when they pushed
you inside I can see there's a little
hole right here okay yeah I'm watching
you I'll let you know when you in their
room you just you just sent me to my
death that's what you're ain't telling
me I'm gonna put me in one of those
burner rings you'll put you in a hot
dryer all right don't get out crazy grab
a sheet these are my sheets what are you
doing get the hell back to work Oh
but listen there's a fight cause that's
another where the people over there what
they're not fighting stop lying and get
back to work nice I might be able to
climb this with Vincent's help
oh no I gotta make these dudes fight hey
you think it's okay what he just said
what'd he say
he said something about your mother and
let me tell you what wasn't pretty six
months old you're talking [ __ ] about my
mom I don't give a [ __ ] what the hell
break it up guys
stop enough get out of the way come on
blood bro oh I gotta let you I gotta let
you I'm coming up coming I'm covered
cake I promise on me Oh God
oh come on oh come on oh come here you
come on in come on man it's nice in here
we got some foods and drinks a dragon
fees there's some of that year too here
here King hit here's some sheets here's
some sheets King there you go grab all
of these grab all the seats come on
shoes look at a photo I don't know
now we need to put the sheets into it
hold the vent right there I think you
have to help me up there first
here we go here we go I'm surprised you
I'm surprised you can lift up my nose
man it's crazy
two ton of nose there a good boy Hey
I'll take it together and if you love
don't you love how somehow he's holding
himself up with this whatever he's
standing on that thing looks like it
will fall as a long box that's 30 Jim
it's to lock it up everything's built
Ford Tough in jail I want to know how
come those guards then come back on top
all right that should do it
yeah let's hope so
not a fan of hobbies do well oh I'm
scared of heights and going by her mojo
so you never know
well good night I'm getting the hell out
of here yo all you gotta do is just let
your nutter your nose drag you down to
the floor watch thinking office don't
you love how everything is ironically in
pairs of two to get anything up really
it's pitch black
we need a light yeah okay
okay
Oh find the flash I got you I got you I
got you I got you I got you I got you
your noodle water hold on
sending the flashlight are you at oh
yeah come back oh oh how the hell did
you end up there I just slid down a bit
to the left
what it was all dark that's why we
needed some light leo
smartass huh I'm concern with our garius
idiot
you good mm-hmm
you doubted me for any for a second
no you in doodle it doesn't matter I'm
not talking about that I've never had
those animations tell me look totally
looks Last of Us oh we have that
flashlight
give me that flashlight
that's my flashlight Macchio's I took it
man okay
it's gonna take Xbox you play the last
of the three I know it looks like we're
on the Xbox we're playing a ways out but
no sense we're actually playing the last
was three ten years from now King
actually listen King actually lives in
Florida he moved to Florida years ago
the Xbox series X is out I'm playing on
this the series
s and Kings played on the series X
one two three we got two together one
two three probably is yeah like I said
let's hope there aren't scared of rats
are you me wrong way I mean like hello
guy there is like there's a sign right
there yeah every area a this way up this
way come on okay
and I'm gonna leave at it let's knock
him out we got we got the weapon of mass
destruction my big-ass nose it's just so
easy everything is this is how for me
everything's ironically able to be
handled in pairs the two like all the
walls can be took out two people are you
kidding me just remember to push against
my back Oh Paul all the time start now
Oh God
go go go go go in it I'm not gonna hit
it you have to hit it next time
Go Go Go Waukee there you go valances
return balance to the force
you ever go hit a king you know you know
that you can fart all right
you trying to destroy your foot I'm not
doing nothing there we go now go oh okay
okay
now he's doing stuff on purpose
come on more MORE
so go you go go go
oh wait wait I missed it Go Go I messed
up we will guide now hold on let me
catch up let me catch up
you're not letting me catch up I'm not
pushing it go go go now your turn Oh
hold on hold on I'll be your leaguer
let's go let's go ok ok I'm coming
ok I'm [ __ ] it [ __ ] that was supposed
to happen we would've died in here
last afraid of heights something like
that are you [ __ ] serious a wrench
would be nice there's only one place you
can get that the workshop yeah damn it
I guess it's the same way down right
yeah no childhood tricks up your sleeve
fraid not [ __ ] alright so you got fired
I was super chat from regular to nine
five one this is not going to be
possible later on after Keene takes
those knees heading touch let's load to
you throw ready tomorrow would feel oh
my god
it would be a little hard of that knees
I'm not gonna lie that's definitely the
case there's gonna be something crazy
when those knees get [ __ ] done with your
nonsense man what's up rolling
this is absolutely stupid why are we
back in jail I could do this all day now
that's what I call a piece of machinery
quiet
try to concentrate
what the hell are you getting so
stressed out about this I don't do this
right they pull me back in the laundry
room
so laundry rule this rule they're both
so
so Bravo d3 wants to know what exactly
is the knee bets
so King has two knee bets right now he's
gonna lose both his knees by the end of
the year so he's gonna lose both of his
knees animal everyone's by the end of
the year but by the January the first
whatever so the most this year yeah but
it only gets initiated if it's in-game
past now why is if it's in game past
before the end of the year it doesn't
matter
so as long as it's in game guys at one
point in time
then the bit starts but that's that so
it has to be in game past before the end
of the year all right so before the end
of the year it's got to be in game where
you used to work and solve enjoying its
son is gonna make you safer back back
probably they do it with Miles Morales
DLC is that the same thing though is
that really the same thing
well you gotta get this dude I got to
get this bunch from this idiot
I can't stop a book loose man like this
alright of both who's doing this way
that's better
how can I both who's doing this over
it's been a long time since I okay
explain that John can be I need you to
put what he's uh added these drinking
while he's using heavy machinery
uh-huh until they blame you for losing
them hey watch it
is it always this hard to get a tour I
want to get a 200 hey guard
can't you see I'm busy here
I guess you're okay so I can't I guess
your bad let the big nose try to get up
then behind the pin
okay well found us [ __ ] what do you
need
it's pretty hard to get any work done
without it and you shouldn't have lost
it I didn't lose it I gave it back to
you yesterday well you better hope
you're right because they can't find it
here you said there was such savages I'm
surprised that Co didn't come out of
that what'd you say I've decided I don't
want to escape from prison anymore King
so I'm just gonna be a hard-working do
you have a hammer I got a hammer
we need a wrench or a wrench okay so
there's that guys from there so when I
talk to this guy
you take the wrench from us okay the
wrench is over here when I talk to this
dude you take the wrench behind him you
come behind on the other side okay
waiting for three people one go Rick
take the right I'm gonna take this this
is mine now go to the back over there
and get your defenses that and put it in
a conversation with this video
yes thinking in that whole bow it won't
let me the whole will not let me stick
it in gold next to the hole to the hole
okay
well you're putting on putting the
wrench in the whole the wrench is in the
hole I'm out of here you gotta come on
I'm coming we're just gonna try to break
out in the middle of daylight I'm coming
don't I told you don't don't scream if
even you get to the other side legal
dimension to that then online they got
touch your body part hey let's go touch
me up fill me up man don't be oh oh you
didn't check my you to check Mario you
didn't check my but we get there 18 it's
easy for you to talk with the lack of
rich let me show you come on let me show
you
[Music]
you bet the gay you bet to get beat
they're fighting let's go oh they're
doing the doing um it's okay because
they're rich
the so Jonathan B said it's kind of
obvious at this point that cyberpunk was
moving to launch alongside the Xbox
series eggs and if that's the case I'm
pretty sure it's going directly in the
game past whoopsy man we'll have to see
see that that's just half the bet man
that's to initiate the bet you still got
a win Oh
[Laughter]
addy got a shorty with on the dance
floor whoo it looks like one of the
freaks it's okay cuz Olivos a fee let me
see the tattoo so you got a bow like
Laura crow
good good you troubled well don't worry
about that
you won't find us and you're sure yeah I
got us a new place we should be safe for
now
why don't got handcuffs on the table but
don't got nobody hang up today why
you're still waiting nobody's coming for
you Wow I'll wait some more
no more about the metal coming in that's
not how it works phone call where you
want to go back to yourself you
they just got random no sir I think I
random inmates is going downstairs yeah
why aren't you here because I'm at home
you expecting a baby
please talked about this
No you've talked about this I didn't
have a say at all you're in prison that
no balls point is this how you want your
future child to remember you no but I
need to take care of the situation
my family my old brother I know you miss
him but you can't this hobby is crazy
cause he's dead to pieces I wasn't here
while I'm out you know this is a Batman
game
it's dekum Park oh no he ain't got no
ride-or-die chick you see the two
different girls one ready to kill Harvey
this lever when talking about leave I'll
be alone
yeah good man oh look at that biometric
fog coming from the steel Salman State
you hear about the weather there's
little toes they collided it's not
window believe tonight I'm ready
doesn't fall in the bushes at it
no I'm so here I'm drinking my propel my
berry flavor like a lemon water all day
well it leaves about the door - Shelton
since I can't go out coz we're playing
this now on door does anything they cost
them much it does
got the wrench yeah just don't drop it
okay
are you kidding me you think I'll do
this climb again oh he's gonna have to
do the climb again we gotta do it again
no we don't have to do it again not
handed nothing over Oh
[Music]
what's up you move with my fast huh
Margo ready yeah
you can get out of jail with Dave for
tool can't believe in my nose start over
until the fat lady sings well she's
gonna say trust me
sure hope so that's well that's what was
both
[Music]
exact animation for The Last of Us
that's right
told you where they got it from let's go
look when leb crawling through stuff
look at that animation look make sure
they should just put at the end of last
of this part - inspired my eyes out but
you squeeze things
hey Leo get over here are you so damn
slow you're trying to get us blocked
back up
man that lightning gonna give me busted
we gotta bust this door open okay on
three over one
g'way rory stamping with the Duggar hold
on wait for the Thunder when they learn
about baby baby baby I know what Thunder
sounds like just a couple of more like
that
what did you do I want to get out no
let's just choke him up man like the
lives of us all get taken down ah it is
you want to take a guard out for a
minute
[Laughter]
watch a min over there bleakie oh I'm
gonna get the water baby back let's go
come on stand right on your nose I gotta
pick you up Last of Us animation
[Laughter]
here you go buddy have fun out there
Freebird you just want everybody anarchy
look man oh thank you you give them the
achievement so what's there gotta be
careful
Bart just went downstairs good right oh
the guests I can't remember I must be
getting old
hope here's the place that we was
earlier
I don't think that leads anywhere I
think we got to just keep going in the
direction can we open this
[Music]
as I did it has a little bit of
Jewishness did you take the guards own
wills
oh so we both have to get up on one okay
ready ready oh I'm no or new users about
to go in there all right
three two one go I've taken them on the
right you take a little left
yes King likes the right there like this
is a nice tattoo King I've never seen
before that I actively be chasing
kneecaps what I did it
oh man I decreed it down or that's it
bro oh well do what I can
[Music]
but you hit that move Oh God you can use
that wire
we just need about now Oh clothes
hangers over you there we go here we go
see on the other side King
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah boy even the bushes look like the
last you need to buy lastest you know
you need to buy last was he just gonna
buy this case there's no need for phone
won't climb that shaft
you know the back-to-back balls I didn't
climb know what sorry in a comic book
once when I was a kid
tell me you're joking sorry I'm just
glad it worked oh my god I can't [ __ ]
believe you talked me into it
me neither
yeah
come there alright you go up the chopper
yeah ask them off
there you see everything they've got we
have to be careful
I'm not going back in
come on leo why are you down there man
I'm coming
I can only climb so fast you went the
wrong way I didn't go there I still got
to the same scenario let's go get up you
don't know me like that
oh [ __ ] cops everywhere we gotta watch
shot yeah there's a sneaking game like
the last of those two you never gonna
take after you then I grope rolls yes Oh
they got dogs addict you know what to do
them let me stab them
I'm a grad this dude all right hey my
god no that's exam clothes you turn
around
Zini check I got mugs I got mom
what's up edit King and Chet what's up
brows moves hi boss boos my bad the
brows we don't got a chunk anybody I'm
joking that's my joke them I'm gonna
take this one let me get down there with
you oh you ain't even over here with me
you gotta take these cops out man put
them all out put them all out kids got
better together okay he's got better
Stella to the Last of Us
tell them about it when I come out the
[ __ ] we have these two down here's me
you together
take them on the left you take the one
on the right we go back to jumpin life
31 good Johnson I'm out of here
they kill Justin let's go yeah hold up
I'm going this way
oh man it's pretty heavy nose you gotta
know these things
oh okay I'm mad cause I catch that dude
hold on the Gate Bridge look at her look
at you all right
too risky I say we take that guy out
take his car across the bridge
what are you crazy a lot of kites boy
okay
Oh holy-o's way I'm a believer where you
about the slope police stop police is
boss so go for speed
there you go run get out of my way go to
the meadow faster furious
Wow
thank you for playing a way out I'm
running man I ain't trying to kill dog
if all my love is slower than us because
this nose weighs too much
[Laughter]
person to have the game join them and
have fun with you and I think it's like
two dollars right now so God get that
diamond
Wow hey just tell him this is the deal
you had to take it go got it
some man Harvey Dent's overhead turned
his face around let me see school face
oh yeah mere polygon here's a large nose
oh wait I go front door got it they got
the black PG down packed like this in
tone is good that shoulders is crazy
though you do man holy hell
all right look at that fruit legit yeah
what's up Leo busted out they got black
people shows he's right [ __ ] it's a bit
of car is he supposed to be dead a guy
[ __ ] up got himself killed by the
guards a lot of kurzon hurt we need to
find him okay yeah but I'm not sure the
men they got did I problem you just need
to find him you got it I don't give a
[ __ ] how just make it happen
yes boss
so you just starburns what are the 1970
okay
No Deal Oh sheets all these nobody did
you played with hello turn that down
that it
whoa look at the foliage
look at that mountain
[Music]
he's like breath with a wild I'm hungry
but I definitely eat it yep anyway let's
head on we should find something on the
way
let's go let's move man I'd die for a
burger well I'll let you know if I find
a burger joint yeah you do that there's
a um he's like an achievement around
here or something like that well fine
it's like you got a fight you got to
find like a place to take a picture or
something like that
I can't remember okay well I guess that
was that mountain I'm not a son I'm
trying to get away from jail so how do
we get close we don't get any cool why
is your pants dirty we're not talking
about that yeah using water and now this
dog this dog here we go shout out to the
real nature wing folk today who knows
those bands other than fish was flying
in the air all right we got glitchy
you look like a regular do it I got a
whole inmate number all over my chest
being take this shirt off yet
how many does this look like so I'm
splashing them to you and you gotta grab
bugs no civilization no toilet paper
fresh air no one will let me catch you
probably probably to light the fire we
can now make a spear so you can stick it
to fish
and now I made a fire now let's go get
the spare
I'm gonna get these fish over to you you
dig them all right just like used to
doing - I'll send them your way
you stick them let's go look at this
fool let's go
dead of time come on no you have to get
two we had to get one for each so give
me the spirit
I got a craft my own spit like I'm in
woodshop Oh Jeffrey Kevin says Lord
added the game looks better than the
last of us three go cook your fish man
and get out of hand get this fish man
fishing fish is all now I catch those a
downward motion okay
fishy fish is separation from your
friends
this dude got a fish and can't splash
the water for me I thought and splash
one of them little get over here man I
splash water for him it's just wait
you get his fish and made me dip out
addict [ __ ] you don't need that fish man
you don't need that fish just go
background star stand with them you've
come across like four of them oh go back
the other way you do like progress
[Music]
they're not let me have the spirit let
me just do it no splash splash it and
walk them towards me come on
you got to walk them at it I'll take
this flash your are you man yeah you
know if you splash you got it walk them
right look anything run down on them you
can't even run down on them I'm gonna
get let him get his active splash off
well you know we just stay there's black
plastic stab in the water
man and I ain't got an actual splash
over here let me have that sphere you
push me come over it unless you know if
you come over you put it down I gotta
catch the fish myself there there's one
right there with a fish already on it
but no it's not you ate it already
not mothers I'm out of them I got my
fish too so wouldn't even need splashes
go have to do you and one face know how
to do you I'm a cook this fish right
here mm-hmm
honey was surely hotter now you chef it
up police searched his gift for wanted
criminals
they stole a police car well you know it
is what it is yeah off the cliff
am i free complaining about this someone
wants to talk her at last was spoils I
gotta tell him that we haven't his
spoiler past we yeah yeah a wife
I hope you kid
I'll [ __ ] listen man yeah here yeah
that piece-of-shit hog he's gonna get
what he deserves let me tell you that so
let's go after him together
I thought we didn't how to do I need to
know what your story was Harvey is know
the game a lot different than that
all right I was a regular guy with a
boring bank job one day my brother
brings in a new client Harvey let me
guess
money laundering yeah money was easy but
Harvey just kept coming in with more and
more cash and I couldn't handle it it
was too risky that's why I told him I
wanted out he killed my brother that's a
warning after that I lost it I plan on
killing him but the son of a [ __ ] pin
it all on me
I was convicted for the murder of my own
brother
Wow that's [ __ ] rough man
that's all we got to catch these names
so what's your story with Harvey [ __ ] me
over that's for sure I hope you kill
this guy's brother about time we get the
police involved right they don't see
that smoke we gotta move don't worry
about it that gun yeah big nose and bad
feet
[Music]
Zama
turn is back online oh that's why we
need a SSD so you used to work in a bank
huh figures what are you implying well
how should I put it
you kind of uptight I'd rather be
uptight than a loose cannon thanks for
the compliment
you're welcome you know what but you're
actually the first guy who worked in a
bank that I've talked to without a gun
in my hand would you look at that
committing progress leo Oh getting this
cabin get a gun
let's see can you hear me of course why
people need to fill the geese well
that's not really a good like I said
that's a horrible patch job instead of
just buying a couple two by fours they
put a piece of metal pull the gig buddy
so two nights ago
[Music]
I'm a knockout the girl you're not got
to do like what to do what could you
knock out the girl okay I knock up the
ground you know that okay this place I
don't like it it's better to get him out
of the house what'd you have in mind see
that barn over there yeah we release the
horses at least the horses how's that
gonna help
trust me I'll be forced to go get them
back I don't know
I want to release the horses are you
doing you July I want us to do the
couple and I want us to do the car
should be on the other side yeah let's
go come on I'm gonna let them shoot you
oh you know this old-timer got a shotgun
you know he got a shot
I'm gonna crap
oh no they do - I just got here no time
damn criminals shut up get the closet
we're gonna leave no crackers in there
with them they go down some no holes
who's with me crack yeah and I saw truck
in the other barn we should check it out
glad yeah you got to put on that pink
hat at it what is it I'll always owe why
do you get the Hat I don't know I used
to be pretty good at this
steady now oh damn
I'm not building that stuff up again
well I'm about to eat my food let's
change thank you like in real life food
so after we get the car started you just
want to call call for the week you come
back for more
I'm out the windows I know and I love
the jacket I told you I've been looking
after I love the jacket now that new is
way too fast there's absolutely no way
we got his son's clothes yourself no no
I got a shotgun man I got a shotgun feel
this good Oh people chairs is the best
I'm out of here
get the drug but you destruct all your
work
don't make me come down there make you
look bad in horseshoes my shoes
okay yeah like I'm nice oh sorry you got
the champion yeah well sir you probably
gonna win oh how you get all three in
one shot you don't know how to play
horseshoes do you if you next to get the
horseshoe rather the metal thing you get
three no you did you just got it close
to it it's not that bad
oh I'm sure there's a spare around here
somewhere
I don't know man it's not like we have a
choice sure beats running on foot let's
fix it
oh they got horses in the barn why
wouldn't they take a horse car with no
wheels this is stupid
do you want do United to ride a horse
I'm not a rider over doc ready Leo I
think it's pretty safe to say that they
don't know how to at all everything's
gotta be in here sorry
all right here's a lug nut wrench yeah
we gotta find a tire furnish King I bet
you there's a tire up there but no
reason up on the roof oh you could throw
it down from the bottom okay yeah I was
I was checking my door to a new tire oh
look at me x over here yo why did I
leave the mud went okay al
[Music]
I guess I have to lift it no I gotta get
the somebody crap little tire goo I
figure it I don't know where it went to
[Music]
the lugworms over now it's attached we
just need to find a lug wrench to fasten
it
the battery seems dead
alright let's lift this thing here move
to support the battery is dead bro
alright now can't you of the animation
that was so wise Luis we got a roll it
looks like the battery's out of juice
what we supposed to we probably gotta
try to get it up a little bit
repair the truck well can we look around
for some for something too
Oh
gas canister I bet it still has some gas
and where you you in here hey I got the
gas canister you gotta find something to
my guess not you well gonna take it's
like a fine arm battery now
yo what up King at attic I missed some
of it because of errands but I did see
an ex horseshoe toss skills or just you
cking oh my god we're gonna make it
about Vivi from garbage is the worst
game of the game on fire
I see some cows
and why you do that I'm gonna play
another game of horseshoes I rock
Judah's out of control other control so
you get the he had their West Virginia
swag saw some horsemen like revealing
over what's my god Virginia's thought
that will be it stop it I'm just good at
games I got to be I'm from West Virginia
saw that play origin I don't believe
that actually look like you did still
gonna let the horses lose hi buddy want
some hey
what so Lunken lure this is an ILP so
I'll address all the members and stuff
alright so I guess I might have to go
back inside the house where the old
people's locked away you go beat we're
batteries out that's right
these are gonna show you what we said
got a shotgun on your back spitting
tobacco
did you just try to call your girl looks
like please his thumb out of juice good
police is coming now
are you drinking their beer for a long
time knowing that old people stuff
leaving the bill before long summer
faces are cold front page you front page
those bra we made it all right you have
a nice diet RDX man we're about to close
shop here in the moment anyway he's
divorce once we get this this truck up
and running we're calling it for the
week well I don't know we'll probably do
at the same time next week depending on
uh who who's doing what but we'll get
back to you guys on that you just keep
track of to what okay is there something
down here that was really like a fire
with that would it's well we said it's
it's a West Virginia truck fill it with
moonshine yo I'm not gonna even I'm not
gonna even remotely talk about this
because that actually does happen here
look I'm helping these old people out
right now I'm a psycho you still got the
gun I do I do don't see look look look
here here's someone we get the battery I
bet you we have to get the battery out
of the car
although there's a place down there I
don't know man I don't know wait you
can't think the better like the
batteries out of juice
let's see if we can get it off of this
alright so they keep telling us go down
there
so we have to I think we have to to
maybe we have to find keys no I just
thought the car I just tried to stop
because those well there's a place down
there for to get the to charge like
right in front of that look if you look
in front of that there's like jumper
cables and everything right in front of
that okay this thing right here
so we gotta push there's a battery there
we gotta push that that the car down the
hill yeah how do we push the car though
behind it this is the ultimate don't
tell you nothing game leasing the last
of us they give you a hand
okay let's see
all right I try to crank it you try to
push you know it's you so
where's my battery
all right say it again
so if it's dead why can't I just take
the battery out of this that's a wood
chopping tongue I don't want to help him
out get out for that seven headaches go
help him out for you kill him my dead
gas can was there that was there we did
all of this horseshoes is here for no
reason at all the hell with that
it's
let's let me show the last chance I
think it's voice because it's not glitch
it shouldn't let us like push the truck
or something man like it literally said
okay let's go alright don't lift it up
yet let's put the tire on first okay so
leave that wrench there let me throw you
across the icy tire over there let's
find a way to get up there
you ready yeah while you do that I'm
gonna get the gas can alright so you put
the tire on you don't lift me up all
right I got you just go get the guys
though ladies lemon I'm a tackler
[Laughter]
there's something down I caught a pinch
bar yeah don't touch that that's a
that's the joint that we use the let the
car roll but I think we did that out of
out of turn canister it still has some
gas
I said you put the tire on well I put
the gas I'm gonna roll it down the hill
[Applause]
okay now we just need to screw in the
Stutz the pellets will fall upon you
Janna I'm messaging called neophytes
filled up with gas wonder if it will
start use this the best in the new tire
we'll get the picture I'll put the lug
nut off I know what's wrong what I can't
read the pencil
or I'm gonna go someone said this is the
best autozone simulator I've ever saw
all right I think we have to lift this
up so we can get this this tree stump
off of it so let me do that lift it up
alright now get that tree stuff that's
under the car Oh Oh guys you know cheese
stop all that cheese go see
so all the time we had to just take the
stump oh no I took the stump off last
time I think English don't you
stops perfectly all right cables
I'll do the cranking great bloop does
actually work this piece of junk yeah I
told you so you did but still I was in
doubt sometimes you just gotta have a
little faith in things Leo thanks huh
yeah well let's get out of here yes No
oh oh he's got a gun you doing the guns
okay hurry up please take him out
are the police on their way yet yes
they'll be here any minute okay I'll go
take care of them no just stay here it's
all right just wait here I'll be fine
yes are you gonna own your land on the
dollar
come on
Oh - man game looks good though
looks like web Redemption oh that's too
much you don't need to be saying some
stuff like that someone move says he
needs to move says King needs to play
the banjo why you chopping wood charge
life on them batteries for the
PlayStation 4 controllers Oh play this
hope I provide a dying first upside that
wolf I can see why they don't want us to
have batteries
get this piece of [ __ ] on a nice day
just sit down the oh you're gonna bum
off alright here we go
Oh God driving and I have to shoot
No
oh this is D for speed we've been caught
by now I gotta team flipped over your
first card
[Laughter]
so this couch is really not playing
then when somebody wants to do the fall
got it
oh do the but the the almost fell out on
the car no worry
when unusual getaways down
ha
they don't like they want hurts and
stuff like this this is how King me
drivin to gamestop when he finds out it
has the last available ps5 install how
am I still in the bag that's what I want
[Applause]
last time was graphic they some horrible
pain cause I was looking at your screen
I was looking at your screen and that
concludes the I enlarge playthrough
layout for this week as we give you the
visuals of the last on the xbox and it's
like and it's like you know what King
you know what King I think that I think
the game plays better on this game than
the license was part two so this is this
is it for the week definitely checking
Twitter will be keeping you updated if
you know we when we're gonna do another
one keep in mind that we're doing these
we're branching out more and what kind
of content we have just for you know our
community our community definitely been
supportive so we want to give back as
much as we possibly can but until next
week
I definitely catch I alors podcast at 1
p.m. Eastern this Sunday and Voula
will definitely give a time when we're
gonna do the skin thing but this is this
game we are looking and we are out of
you